you met Jeffrey Epstein once yep
talk to me about what that's like coming
face to face with somebody
of that caliber
whatever that means um
well
one thing is there is a physiological
reaction that corresponds to this phrase
that you know the hair on the back of my
neck stood on end like that's a real
physiological feeling I don't know
whether the hair actually does that but
it's exactly what it feels like
you're meeting somebody who is Unholy
and
you know one of the most interesting
things is that he was beckoning into a
world that didn't seem to exist but for
him as it as the door
was the doormat
I think that's one of the things that
freaked out a lot of these rich people
is is that he
he felt rich in a movie Sense which is
not something that you find among
actually rich people
what do you mean
well
a lot of very wealthy people don't own
an island
s are really tough to to maintain
I'm obsessed with islands and you know
in general I have to be obsessed with
islands that have airports run by other
people because you know they have
populations on them
but every rich person starts to Wonder
Could I afford it can I afford an island
or how many jets and if you look at
Jeffrey Epstein's wealth it was beaten
it was like gold beaten into gold foil
so that it could cover a vast area and
leave the impression of a solid gold
life
but it was really probably on a mid nine
figure Fortune
that had been used to buy islands and
plays which is not what any nine figure
person is going to
do so you had a
felt sense an embodied sense of
discomfort
oh hell yeah
and where did that come from
uh
the fact that he had a lipstick camera
pointed at me from an art object that he
laid a table that was preposterously
long and thin with a tablecloth made of
an American flag to make it look like a
coffin so that I would spill my coffee
on the flag of my own country I mean the
fact that he looked like a mutant Ralph
Lauren with this kind of lubricious
quality and he's talking all of the
science and Market stuff and nothing
adds up and there's an heiress bouncing
on his knee to get her boobs to jiggle
to see whether it can distract I mean
it's like one of these crazy scenes were
nothing about it was normal there was
just now there was no trace of a normal
world
that sounds like a script from a movie
yeah I mean I think part of it uh John
Travolta is like putting a gun to your
head and forcing you to drink and break
a code in a minute yeah like that part
of it and then there was some sort of
like you know
remember that that story The Most
Dangerous Game where a man invites you
to his Island so he can hunt you
you know this was
scary and it was it was meant to be
scary sounds menacing
well I think his product was silence
people think that his product was sex
or Finance but it was silence I'm pretty
sure how do you what's that mean if
you're scary enough look rich people can
get sex but they can't necessarily get
people to shut up afterwards
so I my take on it and my take on it
instantly was this is not an actual
human
this is a construct of someone's
someone has created a fake human being
called Jeffrey Epstein
who's a mysterious currency trading
financier with crazy rules so that no
one would ever invest with him
and I think that was to keep people from
seeking his Investment Services
I mean he you know he's labeled
disgraced financier but nobody has a
record of trading with him
he was sitting there he comes into the
meeting and he says you know well Eric I
was just doing some currency Trading
and I
I thought about that scene that you
sometimes see and as a meme with Steve
Buscemi with a skateboard over his
shoulder hello fellow Cantina just hello
fellow financial traders exactly so I'm
thinking you don't really look like a
rich guy who trades in markets
the thing that's interesting that I'm
finding myself intrigued by here is
it takes a moderate amount of cognitive
horsepower
to be able to piece together this
theater that you sat down at yeah
deployed in a
nefarious malicious manipulative way
but it's smart
what do you mean it's smart it's it's
not something that could be done by a
simple mind
you think he did it
oh he has a team of manipulators
no when I say I think he was a constrict
I literally mean that I think he was
constructed
like fitted with a story
oh so you think he was a plant
no I think it was a construct what's
that like okay you're gonna have to dig
in I think
Jeffrey Epstein
Super Genius financier
was not a thing that existed
where did the money come from
I'm gonna Mumble Lex West Lexington okay
so that's what Drew mumble
but then you know there's this missing
Fortune of Robert Maxwell and this
Fortune of Jeffrey Epstein that we don't
can't explain are those the same fortune
it's like a conservation of uh of money
principle that if you have a fortune
that's missing and you have a fortune
that can't be explained in there
connected by gillaine Maxwell I don't
know
why is it that no hedge funds what is it
they file form I forget it's 13f there's
certain forms that you have to file
um nobody's ever asked for these things
where who's this Prime broker has
somebody gone over the prime brokerage
uh his what are his trades
he would have to move the market if he
was you know doing a yard of Euros or
Swiss Francs or who knows what as like a
billion
um that would move the market so there's
no way you can fake retroactively a
hedge fund
of immeasurable size that trades
currencies I I don't think he was a
currency Trader he told me it was a
currency Trader So when you say a
construct who constructs who's the
Builder
I don't know I would imagine some
version of the intelligence community
you know sometimes somebody's cover gets
blown
um we have we have a very famous
unfortunate story of Ellie Cohn with the
Mossad where Ellie Cohn was an Egyptian
Jew who was fitted with a backstory that
he was an Argentinian Playboy
who'd made a fortune in Argentina but
was Arabic in origin and then he moves
to Damascus and he takes out an
apartment where he holds orgies
and
becomes the best friend of hafez
al-assad right and so
that's an example of a story we know we
know how the intelligence communities of
the world create people who don't really
exist
construction of I know that this is just
a one time thing here that you got to
see but the construction of the coffin
looking
American flag the spelling of the coffee
this weird power play thing that's going
on
that seems now that you say that uh it
wasn't him even pulling his own strings
perhaps
it makes a lot more sense but even that
that degree of sophistication I learned
this from Daniel schmachtenberger we sat
down and he's spent some time with
particularly powerful people yeah and he
told me this really harrowing story of
somebody who has both the desire and the
means to treat themselves like an apex
predator
against their own kind and they said so
they oh broke the fourth wall about this
and said apex predators don't care about
the prey but they saw their own kind as
prey and I asked Daniel how does it feel
to sit opposite somebody who isn't rate
limited by the resources who can not
only dream to have this
plus uh have the motivation or lack of
virtue or Integrity to go ahead and
consider doing it and then has the
capacity the assets to be able to enact
it sure and it's reminding me it's
giving me this same
something it feels like it feels like
it's up on the top of my head it's
giving me some sort of a sense like that
this was intended to be terrifying it
wasn't an accident
it was intended to be as fascinating as
it could possibly be which it was
and terrifying at the same time and it
achieved both it achieved both
objectives
I mean I was given an opportunity to
meet him again
I didn't know what to do
I mean the other thing that I just found
really weird is that he knew about my
research and it turned out that he was
connected to my graduate department at
Harvard
so he had a connection to the Harvard
math department unbeknownst to me
I don't know when that began
I know two of the professors he was
connected through
but this is some Unholy story it has
nothing to do with Jeffrey Epstein
it has to do with whatever this thing
was we tripped over a thing
we tripped over a structure
we named the structure Jeffrey Epstein
it must be
very unfortunate in some regards for
whoever it was if that's true that was
in charge of
this Construction
that it became that people got t-shirts
with his name printed on them
that this was already going wrong
in the early 2000s
you see my sense of this is that this
was a pre-internet
plan that lived into the internet age
and couldn't survive contact with the
internet age
what did the internet bring in that
didn't allow it to survive eyeballs
discussion level of surveillance well
you know there's a claim that nobody
cares about Jeffrey epsteed because it's
this many years later and we've all
moved on
yeah
that's completely untrue and we know
that it's not true because if you start
talking about Jeffrey Epstein the
engagement goes up
so you have these fictions like you know
they're
put out by mainstream Media or
traditional news desks which is nobody
cares about that story well that you can
see from social media that that's not
true from the internet so the internet
is constantly providing
an ability to check whether or not these
claims from inside the structure true
and Jeffrey Epstein is an example of
what I called an an anti-interesting
phenomena
what's that one anti-interesting thing
is something that would normally be
fascinating
imagine for example you had a story
where you could get a Pulitzer Prize for
breaking it everybody cares you'd sell
papers like hotcakes blah blah blah and
nobody wants to report on it
and it's like right there you could just
ask the dumbest questions and it would
like
New York Times says disgraced financier
well tell me did you find his prime
broker did you find the form did you go
to his offices in vallart house no
nobody does ever
the story is anti-interesting and it's
very different than being uninteresting
which would suggest mole collusion mole
coordination
hello
I mean
see this is what this is one of the most
uncomfortable things
I think there was a time when mostly
when people said collusion or
coordination
the presumption was well that's kind of
that's pretty far out there we now know
like post Elon musk's 44 billion dollar
Adventure at Twitter that there are
these coordinating groups coordinates
coordinating social media with the
intelligence Community or with the
Department of Homeland Security or with
the state department
we now know that we're living in an
orchestrated Court you know curated
choreographed world
and we can't know it officially but we
all know it if we want to know
which is hysterical now we have to talk
about well are you a conspiracy theorist
like
I I read
I read the slack messages I read the
emails what what are you even talking
about now this episode is brought to you
by a product I've used every single day
for over three years now and that is ag1
ag1 is a foundational nutrition
supplement that covers whole body Health
it is a staple part of my supplement
regime I take the travel packs with me
when I'm on the road like here in LA and
it really does make a massive difference
especially to my digestion if your
energy levels have been all over the
place if you really feel like you need
to make an improvement to your nutrition
this is a fantastic place to start it's
been updated 52 times over the last
decade and only uses the best
ingredients at the highest quality to
make sure that it covers all of your
nutritional bases there is a 90-day
money-back guarantee for 90 days you can
use athletic greens and if you do not
like it or are not satisfied with the
results they'll give you your money back
if you're looking for a simpler
effective investment for your health try
ag1 today by going to drink ag1.com
modern wisdom you'll get a Year's free
supply of vitamin D 5 free ag1 travel
packs plus that 90-day money-back
guarantee that's drink ag1.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Eric then press here for the full length
three hour episode
go on
press it